one task you have find baby Yoda you
must the tracking fob died you dwell
where begin your search
would you this is what if and here's
what would happen if you had to find
baby Yoda alright
it sounds like an easy task but we
wouldn't be scouring the 50-million
systems of the Star Wars universe we'd
be doing it in our own galaxy the Milky
Way searching some 100 billion planets
even in a starship equipped with
hyperdrive would take you a lot longer
than your human lifetime maybe to find
baby Yoda you'd have to think like baby
Yoda okay so if you were a 50 year old
toddler with a taste for frogs and the
ability to lift it charging mud horn
into the air where would you hide would
it be somewhere damp and foggy and
soaked with the dark side of the force a
desert maybe or something more
earth-like Master Yoda usually and
finally you will well my feelings are
telling me to start with the world of
jungles and swamps are to set a course
for Dagobah
[Music]
baby Yoda could be all that's left of
Yoda's kind we don't know where his
species comes from or even if they have
a name so why go to Dagobah this planet
might be harsh and humid but it's a
perfect place to hide from the Galactic
Empire but as far as science goes a
boggy planet fully covered in marshlands
is hard to come by in real life
bogs usually form in the lowlands and
require more than a few geographical
features than Dagobah has another
impossible planet to find in the Milky
Way would be the cold gas giant Bespin
the gas giants we know of are mostly
composed of hydrogen and helium a planet
like Bespin would be a poor source of
any heavy elements for mining and it
would have an especially poor atmosphere
for baby Yoda to breathe oh you could
spend millennia searching for a planet
like that in the Milky Way and never
find it
but lucky for you there are better
places to look for this little creature
with a high midi-chlorian count our next
stop would be a Milky Way version of
Tatooine kepler 16b in star wars
Tatooine is a hot arid planet that's
circling around not just one but two
suns real life sir compiler a planets of
the Milky Way orbiting two or more stars
are even harsher than that but because
kepler 16b lies just outside of the
habitable zone it's most likely a cold
gaseous world the size of Saturn and it
most certainly doesn't have what you're
looking for
but desert planets are not that uncommon
in the Milky Way we have one right here
in our solar system desert planets could
be hot like Tatooine or jakku
they can also be cold like Jeddah or our
own Mars the only problem is is that so
far we haven't found any indication of
life on those desert exoplanets we don't
know if any of them could be inhabited
by bacteria let alone Yodas species and
I would rather go somewhere more earthly
like the equivalent of the Republic's
capital planet chorus and there are
candidate planets for a high-tech
civilization to settle right here in our
galaxy one of them
kepler-452b is 1.6 times bigger than
Earth and it's growing warmer every year
if any advanced life forms were to
inhabit this planet they would need to
engineer the planet's climate I doubt
that baby Yoda would enjoy a frozen
wasteland like Hoth its equivalent in
the Milky Way a planet with the catchy
name oh goal 2005 blg 390 lb has surface
temperatures as low as minus 220 degrees
that's nearly as cold as Pluto mom but
it could support life just not anything
big and carnivorous like Wampus neither
could a little one like the planet
called Co Roo 7b a volcanic planetary
cousin of Mustafar this lava world sits
60 times closer to its host star than
the earth is to the Sun the temperatures
on ko reus Evan be reached as high as
2,200 degrees maybe you just have to
look for the most adorable planet in the
Milky Way galaxy or maybe you don't have
to go far at all scientists discover
hundreds of new plant and animal species
right here on earth every year
and I'm hoping that one day they'll
discover baby Yoda and I hope it happens
before he turns 900 may the force be
with you always
oh and while you're searching watch out
for any death stars you never know who
might have built one but that's a story
for another what if
[Music]